[Music]
a local nonprofit helping grandparents
raise grandchildren received some
national exposure recently
eight news now featured us in november
and one of the producers from the kelly
clarkson show saw the eight news now
feature
and they called and invited me on the
show
and that was a big deal joyce eatman
featured on kelly clarkson's show last
week she got an opportunity to share all
about her efforts with her non-profit
grants for grants here in southern
nevada nationwide there are more than 3
million grandparents raising grandkids
for a number of reasons some of the
parents have passed away are behind bars
or simply not fit to care for children
since the appearance joyce has received
a number of calls from grandparents
needing assistance across the country
she's done her best to connect them with
agencies in their state since her
fundraising efforts are only for people
here in las vegas
i was so happy and pleased with channel
8 and the local support we get and you
know it's always a big help when the
media helps uh what happens people that
need our help find us and then people
that can help us find us so it's always
a wonderful situation but getting that
call was really exciting
if you are a grandparent or a need of
help or if you're interested in donating
to the charity go to our website at
eightnewsnow.com where we have a link to
the grants for grant's website for you